الشهيده داح من بنت عمي هي بتبقى استشهدت
داخل الهلال وين ملعب الصاله وهي راحت
تطمن على الناس في كان شهداء راحت تسحبهم
و
تامنهم من القناصات اللي قبال الهلال مش
برا الهلال جوا الاصابات صاروا اه راحت
تسحب مشور من برا من جوا داخل الهلال يعني
داخل الحرم راحت تسحب الشباب اللي
استشهدوا دخلهم اجا طلق من هنا خش في
قلبها حتى هي لما نستشهد احنا صعوبه كانت
قاعدين مش قدرين نامها انه نطلعها يعني نن
في امكانيتنا نلحقها نا رحنا ولفينا من
ورا كسرنا حيطه الحيطه الثانيه خشنا على
المخزن المخزن على الممتازه لما مرقنا على
الملعب طلعناها عننا طاقم طبي كان في
المستشفى كل يعني عمليات
تفر الكاز والصار شي المصدر بني ادم انه
يعيش اجتنا الدباب امبارح معكم 10 دقائق
تخلوا الهال كله انت شو 10 دقائق متخيل
الناس اللي فييه الناس اللي فيه انه ع
دقائق نطلع من الهلال ايش تطلع تطلع مين
شيل لما تشيل شلنا صغارنا باولادنا
باطفالنا كلنا وطلعنا وغير انه طلعنا كمان
على المحسوم غلب نقب
نقوا طلاق نار كان والدبابات حوالين
الهلال وطلعنا واخذوا ابن وجوزي كمان فقدا
زعق عليهم وخشو جوا شلهم في البكسرات
ورقهم ما بنعرفش عنهم ايشي احمد محمد ابو
محسن ومحمد ابو
محسن طمنوني على ابني بس اشوف كيف الكل
بقوللك عدم
وهم
شفنا ايش بنشوف جسس جسس البني ادمين
قاعدين بتتحلل قدامنا مش قاعدين يسحبوا
ولا جسه ل بطلع وقنصوه قنص ممنوع حدا يطلع
من باب الهلال احنا كنا عايشين في باص في
باص بره الهلال اه ونروح اكلنا وشربنا
وطحنا وكل اغراضنا فيه ولكن ايش كانت
الامور صعبه من ناحيه انه فيش اكل في شرب
حصار الميه يعني وين وين لما نلاقيها
اه اطلع من الشبابيك الميت قدامنا المتحلل
قدامنا اخر 15 يوم كانت صعبه صعبه ولاكل
ولا شرب ولا حاجه وحاصروا للان وقالوا لنا
اطلعوا اطلعوا بلاش نموتكم هلقيت اطلاق
نار بهبل وشهداء ومرمي في الشوارع البسس
بتاكل فيهم
والكلاب اه والله شوده والدبابات دا شات
عليهم م فغص المصار طالعه والله شفنا
حاجات بترعب يا ابن
الحلال